[Musique]
papapapa bas
à
et
[Musique]
mama mama papa tu attends tu te tais tu
étais tout est beau temps en temps en
temps par la voix
c'est le seul instrument de musique pop
achetés au magasin
effectivement avec notre voix en la
modulant nous pouvons non seulement tout
reproduire tout imiter mais également
tout interpréter lingois la peine
l'amour le mensonge la voix c'est
également l'instrument que nous écoutons
le plus au quotidien effectivement toute
la journée du soir au matin
nous parlons nous sommes parlés nous
écoutons nous sommes nous sommes écoutés
ça n'arrête pas mais contrairement au
son de la voix du nourrisson auquel nous
sommes suspendus ce petit baby mans ce
petit pleure ce petit raw nous
n'écoutons guerre le son de la voix de
l'autre vous souvenez-vous du son de la
voix de votre voisin qui vous a dit
bonjour tout à l'heure
sans doute pas aujourd'hui nous écoutons
les mots mais plus le son alors vous
effectivement qu'écouter vous
mais d'où vient notre voix d'où
vient-elle transporté par une cigogne
mais non mais non notre voix prend
naissance dans celle de l'autre par
mimétisme
effectivement nous héritons des cavités
résonna trice de nos parents mais c'est
par mimétisme que nous allons prendre la
voie ou un bout de voix de notre père de
notre maire de voix qui ont compté dans
notre vie un enseignant un instituteur
une institutrice un ami un ennemi la
voie du boucher la voie du curé que
sais-je par mimétisme donc notre voie va
prendre par exemple l'accent du sud
si votre voix a été élevé dans l'est je
ne sais pas imiter l'accent l'est ou du
nord
votre voix prendra cet accent si vous
avez un ami bègue vous pouvez devenir
bègue par mimétisme
c'est ça la voix alors mon métier de
coach vocal de professeur de chant
consiste à relier la voix et les
émotions parce que la voix c'est
effectivement des schémas familiaux que
nous allons reproduire une voix un petit
peu apeurée un petit peu timide une voix
forte
moi par exemple quand j'étais gamin je
t'ai gros comme un tonneau
c'est pas sympa de dire ça j'étais promu
un avenir d'éboueurs c'est ce qu'on me
disait ma mère était violente et ma mère
prenait un malin plaisir à me savate et
sous la table de la cuisine
et vas-y que je te file des coups de
pieds vas-y mois mathieu inconscient
qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai développé
l'unique arme qui était à ma disposition
de petit gamin ma voix cette voix que
vous entendez là maintenant que je peux
encore tabre est comme ça pour dire
maman arrête mais maman arrête de me
frapper
madeleine madeleine vient me consulter
madeleine est juive
elle est au bord d'un gros groupes du
cac 40 et a une peur panique de prendre
la parole en public
une peur panique au point de pleurer je
reçois madeleine dans mon studio je la
chose d'un casque et nous devisons
ensemble comme je fais d'habitude pour
effectivement procédé à une sorte de
psychothérapie vocale nous mettons à
jour avec madeleine au bout de quelques
séances le fait que dans la maison
familiale où elle habitait ses parents
avaient instauré une loi implicite
disant qu'on ne pouvait ni parler fort
donc sauter ni chanter ni écouter de la
musique
par respect des grands parents victimes
des camps
donc on se rend compte là que madeleine
effectivement est prisonnière dans une
cellule
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il faut
parler retrouvé la clé re fluidifier
réouvrir cette cellule et permettre in
fine et à madeleine aujourd'hui de
pouvoir chanter c'était un long
processus de pouvoir parler et de
pouvoir finalement être avec sa voix
alors je me pose souvent la question et
nous allons faire l'expérience tous
ensemble ce soir je trouve
qu'effectivement toute la journée
nous improvisons nous parlons reparlons
comme je disais tout à l'heure mais nous
sommes jamais à ce que nous disons on ne
réfléchit pas à ce qu'on dit quelques
hommes politiques le font quelques
philosophes mais nous dans la vie
courante
c'est pas notre cas alors nous allons
faire l'expérience ensemble de dire une
simple phrase en ne pensant absolument
pas à ce qu'on va dire
et ensuite la redire en étant vraiment
là dans le lieu je vous indiquais alors
cette phrase c'est je suis chez ce cher
serge alors non s'il vous plaît restez
discipline est resté avec moi rester
avec moi
donc nous allons tous ensemble ne
réfléchit pas nos régimes réfléchissez
pas ah pardon à ce que vous allez dire à
mon signal vous allez donc dire je suis
chez ce cher serge allez-y
c'est nul donc maintenant on va redire
cette phrase est effectivement on va
penser mais où suis-je
où suis-je fermer les yeux et dites vous
que vous êtes effectivement chez ce cher
serge alors pour ça on va ralentir le
débit est articulée et on va ré et on va
répéter ensemble cette phrase je vous
écoute
voilà c'est pas si difficile que ça
prenait donc inspiration aller puiser
dans ce puits effectivement on parle
beaucoup de pleine conscience mais
d'être vraiment à ce que l'on dit la
voix comment ça marche encore quelque
chose d'incroyable pour ça on va changer
de culture
on va changer de pays et je vais vous
expliquer comment fonctionne la voie
d'abord j'aimerais que vous me disiez en
italien bonjour c'est band george north
allez-y mais voilà pourquoi ça parce que
la voix c'est quoi la voix
ce sont des couche de lasagnes mais oui
nous avons ici un muscle qui s'appelle
le transverses
nous avons ici les tripes nous avons ici
une ceinture abdominale qui s'appelle le
diaphragme qui veut dire en grec
paroisse et nous avons enfin les poumons
alors comment ça marche
le transverses pas pousser va faire
activer les tripes qui vont pousser le
diaphragme le diaphragme va monter quand
vous parlez le diaphragme monte va
compresser les poumons et une pression
d'air sort plus on va pousser ici sur ce
muscle
plus le son va être important je vous
demande de vous lever s'il vous plaît
nous allons ensemble encore une fois
prononcé une phrase que nous avons tous
prononcés
c'est à dire les enfants à table alors à
mon signal vous allez le faire mais
encore une fois sans sans vraiment
penser à ce que à ce que vous dites
d'accord
allez-y c'est pas mal maintenant donc en
ralentissant le débit et en appuyant sur
à table sur ce muscle du transverse vous
allez pouvoir me dire les enfants à
table
attention on y va mais bien sûr papa et
maman mais qu'est ce qu'on va manger ça
a l'air bon ce que vous allez préparez
vous pouvez vous asseoir
je vous propose maintenant de vivre tous
ensemble une petite ergothérapie et
avoir le bonheur non pas de chanter tous
ensemble mais de travailler et de faire
des sons avec votre voix je souhaiterais
que nous devenions tous ensemble un
orchestre comme un grand orchestre qui à
l'ombre 8 et les images d'un film avant
de visionner ce film nous allons répéter
donc la première séquence de ce film
c'est la ville donc dans la ville il y a
des voitures
il y à des piétons qui marche une rumeur
il y a j'ai pas des sirènes il ya et
c'est donc je vous écoute allez-y
les klaxons des klaxons
[Applaudissements]
un peu plus de klaxons
bon là c'est un petit peu des dégâts le
mandant choix dans un match de foot
alors justement cet ego thérapie c'est
ça qui est important
n'essayez pas de hurler essayez de vous
fondre dans la masse
soyez à l'écouté de l'autre un klaxon à
un piéton et c'est donc on y retourne
c'est pas la peine d'aller très fort
allez-y
jackson
très bien donc ce sera la première
séquence delà du film
ensuite nous allons avoir une séquence
de petites pluies
alors comment on fait la pluie comment
fait l'appli la pluie on va doucement va
faire allez-y petit puis comme ça
encore encore encore grande pluie voilà
banque puis à les y aller dit
voilà donc je commence à être un peu
mouillé oui
donc la troisième séquence nous ferons
la grande pluie en rajoutant du vent
allez si le vent et le tonnerre alors le
tonnerre c'est pas bon non le tonnerre
sa plaque ses ventes aux nerfs allez-y
n'oubliez pas grand
ok le plus difficile je vous dis ça va
être en fête et a encore une fois
n'oublions pas le terme que j'ai employé
nous faisons là nous sommes un orchestre
donc on doit pas entendre un pupitre
plus que l'autre est donc le moment
difficile de cette séquence c'est que
nous avons la petite pluie la grande
pluie rajouter le vent doucement la
pluie qui continue le tonnerre le
donnait à ses cris ses pas
j'ai l'impression d'être au club mais
n'a pas arrêté là non je ne cherchais
pas les applaudissements donc n'oubliez
pas non mais c'est important parce que
le film va passer les spectateurs
arrivent dans quelques secondes
donc n'oubliez pas ne leur fait pas s'il
vous plaît petite pluie grande pluie et
en rajoutant du vent donc par dessus
avec le tonnerre d'accord ensuite nous
allons donc faire un faye doubt donc on
va on va descendre doucement et là le
ciel bleu va apparaître petit oiseau
cigale avec les oiseaux toujours voilà
bien ensemble soyez bien ensemble on
répète une dernière fois petite pluie
arrête arrêté c'est bon petite pluie
grande pluie avec le vent et le tonnerre
mais la pluie doit continuer et il faut
qu'on entende le vent alors attention on
recommence petites pluies deyr
vingt enfants ciel bleu cigale attention
le spectacle va commencer
vous êtes prêt attention silence absolu
françois tu es prêt donc vous êtes
l'orchestré symphonique vous allez donc
bruitées ce film attention film tedx
vaugirard aude première attention
[Applaudissements]
à
[Rires]
ok
n'est ce pas n'est ce pas merveilleux
franchement je suis très ému non mais
c'est super c'est super est ce que je
voulais vous dire pour terminer sexy
effectivement vous prenez nous prenons
le temps d'offrir leçons de notre voie
aux autres
un chauffeur de bus un voisin dans la
rue et si l'autre effectivement nous
offre le son de sa voix et qu'il nous
sommes prêts à l'accueillir
j'imagine que nous entendrons un petit
peu mieux
merci bravo
[Applaudissements]